Here I'm showing a simple 256 by 256 sample image.
And what we will do now is look at how we can apply various types of Gaussian,
kernels to it.
Let's start off with the most simplest one.
Now here I'm using sigma of 1 pointed, kernel, round, and
as you go away from the center, 0 0, it gets closer to, to being 0 values.
The resulting image here is blurred, but not extremely blurred.
It's got a little bit of defocusing going on.
But as I increase the variance to sigma 3, you can start noticing more blurring.
Similarly as I move to sigma 6, even more blurring is visible.
And, finally moving all the way up here, we can basically sigma 9, and
it's the most blurred image there is of the sequence here.
And that's an important part for us to remember, that basically now by changing
sigma, which is basically the variance, we've basically increased the extent of
the smoothing from one point across the whole image.
And again the kernel here was different sizes.
And we can play around with, of course, the neighborhood size of the kernel too.
So this basically now shows us we can use Gaussian Filters for smoothing.
It's something we will actually play around with a lot in the rest of
the lecture as we start getting into things like kernel filters and
stuff like that